CLASSIFIEDUM BF WY
HAT TH
CLASSIFIEDNFON BEING
KEPTT MAR-A-LAGOMER
PRESIDENPACH HOMD 1 SETSFIED
MARKED TOPECOF
L IDES OF THE AISLE ARE
LEE MORE INFORTION O
EXTLTHE SEAR.CHIFF, THEOCRATIC
AI
COMMITTEE, HAS ASKED THE DITIONM
GHT BE OF ALL ESASEING O
ICG FBI DIREOR
CHRISTELER
Y THIMMEDIATE THRECT OCT THEY
RETZ HAS TS
G.NTSE
R LD TRUMPES AE ICERWEO CLASSIFN
LEARNED UR CIMSTHE IS PAS GATIOS
RECORDS STIL
D RECORDS
E FLNES G UPLY FACILITIES.
TOEARCH OF
MAGO.A MEETING IN
AND A SUBPOENA FORE RECORDS BEFR
UNRSHY FEDER UTORS MAY HAVE SEEO
CORDS THAN TO GO
'T GOING TO EN BY ENT'S AM
THAT MUCH .RUMP AND SOME OF
ADVISE
PRESIDENT.HA H
ENT IS
G INVESTIGAT HE,
N OFCE,
SHOVERNMENT
A
CLS OF THESERDMA
WHRS AS THE JUSTICE
DEONNUO STIGATE IS HOWEN
RETROL OF VE T
THRAL GOVERNMENT F TR AND A HAL.
AL WT HAPPENS IN J CO F ARE CRI.
ANTR NARROW
DOWN MISHANDLED
THESE DOMENTS IF THAT INDEEDCUR.
BORI ABA TATTHANK U SO
>>SEARCH OF GO, THEY HAVE BEEN B
SOURCE TELLS ATERSONA
EMPLOYEES IS ENTS THAT WE BTHEY
MUDD., GRATEF YOUHT AND EARLY OE
R  T
HI GAME,S
EMCALVES MEMBERSF .
THE NUERSIWHEN I FACED E
IS A FRINGEEXTREVE WHEN
THEY R MESSAM
IS
ACCESO W FD D VICE AMERICAN
INTERVENTION OVERSEAS.G TOLDYOS.
PAT I
33LL OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE ENERGIZED A W
SAW THAT ON JANUARY W  DAYAGO
OFFICE OR
WH IENT WILL INTERPRET TO SAY IT
IS OY SOMETHINETA
LOKE O
OPERATE MOST COVERA LOSE THEIRRE
IT?
SHOULDN'T AT CHANGE?
>>
OF 5ACROSSU'RE AN FBI
THE COUNTRY, YOU HAVE A BILITY
CYBERSECURITY, THAT HAPPENS ALL
THINGS CAL
ADN CITIZENS T
COMM CITIZHEM S W
THINGS LIKE DNONRKS.
INTERACTION EVERY DAY.
YOU HAVEMANTS COME IAN
TALKO THE FB
THEY'RE SENG OTHINGS LIKE
WHITE COLLAR CD AT THE HEADQUARO
BUILDING, I'M WALKIN
SO PEOPLE ARD WHEN  SOME THAT HI
A PLACE LIKE CINCINN IF I
WERE STILL TAKING THAT WALK DOWN
NSYLVAENUE, IF
YO O
ULESTAURANT IN CINATMILY, YOT
ER UNTICATWA
ERSTAN
EXPERIENCE.HIAKE OF THE
SOME REPUBLICANS FOR
THTOCO J OF THIS SEAH?T THU
BLE DOING THATF
WERE HIM
N RST OF ALL, WE KEEP GOING BACK
THIS IS A AS
ICANIZ DESVES
IV INDICTED.
THIS PN CUD
FORMALLY OF S YOU HAVE THE
WEIGHT OF THE FE
GOAY PERORR THT OF
THE UNITED STATES, IS NOW GOINTA
BRIEFING, THAT PERSON ISCRI WOUG
REMEMBERF YOU'RE THE FBI --
UNINTENDRNEY GALW OF
THE DOOR BY STARTING TOER THEO
RR T PRE.
ST T CASE, ATTORNEY GENERAL
OPNEED UWE